I think that what a lot of people are
struggling with here is that you know
you were an MIT physics major yep you
are by all accounts a very smart guy how
is it possible that you overlooked this
more than five billion dollar problem
I ask myself a lot how I made a series
of mistakes that seem they don't just
seem dumb they seem like the type of
mistakes I could see myself having
ridiculed someone else for having makeup
the kind of mistakes that I would have
considered myself to have been above
thank you
as we've learned about what happened
over the past few weeks we've learned
that there are some issues involving
where customer funds were put for FTX
and some accounting issues can you walk
us through what the problem was on that
side right you rewind to 2019 2020 FTX
didn't have bank accounts and that was
because as a global crypto exchange at
the time almost none of them were able
to get you know global banking some
customers still wanted to onboard Fiat
currencies though you know FTX was
maintaining cryptocurrency wallets
um but not not banking uh accounts
and so some of them would wire money to
Alameda
um and then asked to be credited on
their FTX account
[Music]
how much of this customer money was
wired to the Alameda bank accounts
I don't have the numbers in front of me
but my estimation is I think more than
half
more than half more than half of almie's
total position came by that method
uh so how many billions of dollars are
we talking about at least ballpark I
think north of five and so this was
actually US dollars that people
customers transferred to Alameda bank
accounts and they were credited for it
on FTX yeah that's right so more than
five billion dollars were transferred
into these Alameda bank accounts yep it
was then credited so that customers saw
that they had that balance on their
screens yep what actually happened to
the dollar sitting in those bank
accounts one phrasing if it one could
use would be to say that Alameda
effectively sent those dollars from its
FTX account to the user but that that's
a ledger transfer of course outside of
that the answer is they were wired to
Alameda I can only speculate about what
happened after that
so you don't know what happened to those
five billion dollars they were I mean
their wire telling me that I wasn't
running Alameda but
um uh I can I can now go back and take a
guess at what
you know where they were ultimately
spent
um or used or something but dollars are
fungible with each other and so it's not
like this one dollar bill over here that
you can trace through from start to
finish what you get is more just Omnibus
pots of assets of various forms
[Music]
was there double counting going on
there was not double counting from ftx's
financials ftx's financials were
correctly effectively debiting this
amount from Total customer balances on
FTX
so let's say Bob wires a hundred dollars
to one of these Alameda bank accounts
Bob checks his FTX screen FTX has
credited his account that says he's got
a hundred dollars yep but behind the
scenes Alameda goes and does something
right that money yeah Alameda has
negative one I was a 100 said at 100
yeah yeah you know Alameda then should
have negative 100 on FTX right because
effectively or at least that would be
one way to mechanic this right would be
Bob sends to Alameda over here off of
FTX or wire transfer then on FTX Alameda
sends to Bob but the whole key there is
you need to keep track of that negative
Alameda piece of the fact that Alameda
is crediting other people of us that
should be debiting
from the funds that they have on on FTX
so this problem developed in which
five billion more than five billion
dollars of user funds was sent to
Alameda and it was not properly seen in
the systems it made alameda's position
seem less large than it was you only
became aware at the beginning of
November I don't remember the exact date
but he's somewhere around there yeah I
was surprised at what happened
um when you added those numbers together
I don't know exactly when
that neutral became so large that wire
transfer piece I think it was
surprisingly recently given that it was
because this was this was a sort of
Legacy system right we transitioned away
from this system over time but I think
that some people just kept wiring to
Alameda anyway
um even after we had built out our own
payment networks and removed any traces
of that old pathway and so I think it
was maybe surprisingly recently that a
lot of that happened as well was Alameda
using this money that came in to that
account
as part of its collateral on FTX
I don't not to my knowledge but I'm not
sure
but that is possible that that was how
it was being used
I don't know what they you know what
they did with which
pieces of assets and given that dollars
are fungible with each other at the end
of the day I'm not sure it's even well
defined to talk about whether it was
those dollars or other dollars that were
sent somewhere but if a dollar went in
yep to one of those Alameda bank
accounts yep then it would have become
part of the customer's margin position
and part of alameda's margin position
it would have if it had gone to an
Alameda bank account then it would
become part of the customer's collateral
on FTX right and it would have increased
alameda's margin position on FTX
effectively
thank you
I wanted to ask about FTX terms of use
yep they say that you control the
digital assets held in your account they
can't be loaned out except there's also
another part of the terms of use that
talk about margin training in which
there is actually language that says
your money could be loaned out and it
could disappear if somebody's trade goes
bad on FTX uh did you have to opt in to
do Market engine Trading so for the
peer-to-peer borrowed lending order book
you did yes how many people and how much
money was actually in that I don't know
exactly at the top of my head I think it
was I want to say eight or ten billion
dollars at the peak
um I don't know what it is today
were you sweeping people into margin
trading and allowing their collateral to
be loaned out
I honestly off the top of my head I
don't know exactly what procedures we
used uh to determine whether an account
was you know doing marching trading or I
do remember
um you know a way that people could have
opted into it but uh I don't know off
the top of my head was there a violation
of the terms of use
I don't know if a violation of the terms
of use
um I don't know every line of the terms
of use I can't confidently say there
wasn't but uh I don't know of one
[Music]
in some of the court filings uh the new
uh head of FTX has said that there was a
secret exemption for Alameda from the
normal Auto Liquidation protocols which
some people have called a back door can
you tell us about this secret exemption
I don't know exactly what was being
referred to there I've that has not been
communicated to me beyond the public
statements nor was I consulted or asked
on that so I can only speculate about
what was being referred to there my
guess is that that may have been
referring to wires sent to Alameda I'm
not sure
um I it made I yeah I can't speculate on
exactly what uh what he was referring to
there but could Alameda be Auto
liquidated
like any other
customer
I don't again have access to all this
right now I believe that there was
um
a system in place that
I think Alameda and some other accounts
were using which did have some
liquidation policies but which were
specific for larger positions I actually
don't know the details of that these
were things that I think like account
managers and legal were working out
together
um over the last year and I was not
deeply involved in that process I do
think that the larger accounts did have
some amount of you know extra margin
capacity in some cases
so Alameda could take on riskier trades
than other FTX customers I'm not sure
but I think there may have been cases
where at least it could take on larger
positions
how is it that as a 90 owner of the firm
and founder of the firm who was close
with the leadership you didn't know was
going on the thing is I was busy I was
you know FTX was a full-time job I was
more than a full-time job and I didn't
have enough brain Cycles left to
understand everything going on at
Alameda if I wanted to I also didn't
want to because I was concerned about
conflicts of interest and I felt like it
would be inappropriate for me to be you
know looped into you know certainly to
details of what was going on there it
caused me to not dig in very much to not
try to engage very much on what Alameda
was doing it was a huge
oversight obviously
um but I
you know the honest answer is
I mean obviously should have been Sam
what you've described sounds at a
minimum like gross negligence
obviously there are a lot of people
there who think that you committed
outright fraud
do you expect to go to prison
I'm not focusing on that right now I
don't think I I you know tried to commit
fraud anywhere here I was trying to do
the best I could obviously that wasn't
nearly as good as I thought it was
um but but honestly it's not what I'm
focusing on right now I don't it's about
the customers at the end of the day like
that's there's one of me there are
millions of them and
I I don't think it's right for me to be
focusing on what happens to me here I
think I should be focusing on
what can be done for customers